Americans it seems like America as a
whole is going back to I don't want to
make it seem like it's radical but kind
of it roots and its culture of just
keeping the government accountable and
if you won't take care of this nation we
will cuz that's kind of how the founder
fathers were I feel like just Americans
as a whole they're going to start making
the founder fathers proud and that's not
saying to start a revolution or anything
or even no promotion of stand on your
rights yeah they're standing on the
rights and they're telling the
government they've taken too much power
give it back to the state I mean this
was Abbott's criticism of immigration
for for a long time now that there are
laws in the books that the federal
government could choose en force and
they don't in fact they have let this
become a a increasingly burdensome
problem for the states to deal with and
then telling States they can't do
anything to stop it and so I think in
some ways this rise of you know a state
Governor that is willing to do something
is uh inspirational I think it's more
likely that border states would follow
suit and I actually wonder if it's going
to be the the States along the northern
border they're going to do something
something too right they're seeing a
wave of immigration as well